so what was it like um after your career
started to take off on true blood all of
a sudden you have agents who
like are actually um you know making
money
et cetera et cetera so it must have been
like a a period that was like filled
with change on multiple fronts
i mean yes yes and no i think you know
a lot of that happens and then you have
to decide as an individual how much of
it you embrace
um so i think absolutely i got
better opportunity i had fantastic
representation that was
not you know uh available to me previous
to that
um which meant i was able to audition
for more and more interesting projects
um the in terms of sort of
public eye and view and things like that
i very quickly decided to just step away
from that it
i this is not that strange for actors
but i think people are surprised to hear
it
i generally don't like being the center
of attention
um unless i am acting unless i'm in that
space and that's
sort of the most i will confess to you
deborah i'm the same way
yeah i think it's that surprises some
people but i think it's more common than
we
give it credit for it yeah knowing even
when i know about you that makes sense
[Laughter]
when you've been dorky your whole life
you just sort of go don't look at me
[Music]
all right welcome back to yank speaks
everybody
we got a great episode today deborah ann
wall joins the podcast for those of you
who are true blood fans of the hbo show
you may know her i know her from the
netflix series daredevil and i'm a fan
you're gonna love this conversation also
quick reminder on thursdays now we are
back
thursday episodes are back the future of
we just did the future of energy you
guys loved it and upcoming we've got one
i'll leave it a surprise of what it is
but the infamous carly riley will be
back joining which many of you have been
asking for her to come back so we've got
a great episode the future of coming on
we've got new guests coming in we're
talking about cloning soon
we are talking about the mars rover we
are talking about
gaming we're talking about all these
different things coming up down the pike
so you don't want to miss our thursday
episodes as well
but for now tune in folks deborah and
wall joins after a quick word
from our yank speak sponsors thanks
y'all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
new sponsor alert this episode of yank
speaks is brought to you by
calm so if you're quarantining in cobid
right now your routine has been
completely
disrupted and for me when i'm off my
routine i don't wind down the right way
and so when i'm on my phone i'm
scrolling that stuff like gives you
endorphins and it's tougher to fall
asleep and what i love about
calm is that it helps you calm down and
relax so we're excited to partner with
calm which is an app designed to help
you ease stress
and get the best sleep of your life and
when you relieve anxiety and improve
your sleep you feel better in every part
of your life and what's great about it
you can be scrolling through your phone
you're like oh wait i need to go sleep i
need to calm down and pop open
the calm app it's got a whole library of
programs designed for healthy sleep like
soundscapes and meditations and 100
sleep stories narrated by beautiful
soothing voices like kelly rowland just
whispering sweet nothings in your
ear as you fall asleep so listen to the
show we're offering a special limited
time promotion of 40 off a calm premium
subscription
at com.com 40 off unlimited access to
calm's entire library with new content
added every week so get started today
calm.com
yang that's calm.com
[Applause]
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by your favorite
hello tushy the coolest bidet company on
the planet
this is frankly the future of toileting
they figured it out in europe it's time
for us to figure it out here
it's a joke because they've been using
bidets for centuries but they've always
been expensive costing thousands of
dollars
and now the new brand new hellotushy 3.0
is here to level that playing field it's
stylish eco-friendly easy to
install and affordable it's pretty cool
it attaches right to your existing
toilet no electricity or additional
plumbing and it cuts toilet paper used
by 80
which is great we love saving money we
love helping the environment less paper
less money all things are great you've
got a 60-day
try it risk-free guarantee and a
12-month warranty
and these new ones essentially clean
themselves so it's pretty freaking cool
so here's how you do it go to
hellotushy.com get 10
off because you're listening to this
podcast plus you get free shipping it's
a special offer just for yank speaks
listeners so go to hellotushy.com
yang for 10 off hellotushy.com
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to yang speaks
incredible actress role model of
millions
someone that i've admired personally for
years uh in part because i think she's
somewhat avowadly geeky deborah ann wall
deborah welcome
hi thank you so much for having me i had
no idea
and yes i am i am a validly geeky is for
sure the right way to say it
so i you know i feel like a lot of
people first discovered you
um as an actress in true blood and then
other people
might have um become a fan during
daredevil netflix which
holy cow if there was any show that
should have been on for
like forever
[Laughter]
in my mind it was that show but you've
been working for years beforehand
um and one of the things i love to ask
people particularly people who are
creatives
um like you is how the heck do you get
your start because it seems like the
hardest thing in the world
it is really hard and i i you know i
talk to students from my college in high
school and things sometimes and they ask
the same question and i don't always
know
that i have the answer um i do think
that if you want to be
in a creative or artistic career um
it's absolutely possible it will happen
for you it's just about
sticking with it um and if and i know a
lot of people who chose not to and that
is a perfectly valid decision i've come
up against that line a number of times
myself where i'm like
look i'm good at math i'm just going to
go teach math or something like that
something that has some stability
so about the geeky imagine if deborah
and wall showed up in your uh
class as your math teacher and you're
like is this is this a tv show what's
going on
i'm teaching algebra now i'm done with
the industry
so yeah so it's hard to just stick with
it so you grew up in brooklyn
your parents i don't think we're
creatives in the same way not the same
way my father's an architect
which has creative elements to it and my
mother's a teacher which i imagine does
as well
um but my father worked in the sort of
community
or i guess he's retired mostly now but
in the community housing so
building and designing homes for people
getting off the streets off drugs that
kind of thing
and my mother taught middle school
english and history
so did you then uh get bitten by the
theater bug
in high school was it around that time
frame earlier i actually
can't remember a time when i didn't want
to do this
so i don't know how i knew but there are
videos of me at like three years old tap
dancing around in my living room for my
parents
and i just knew somehow so you you were
uh a natural or naturally drawn to it
and then your parents
apparently recognized it very early on
so
you like i live in new york and so when
you go to
plays and shows they're occasionally
like child actors
come out so the first thing that came to
my mind was like was deborah one of
these people that i see
like running around that was not
unfortunate in fact
uh one of our favorite plays when i was
growing up that we went to see was full
moon which is bill irwin and i'm
forgetting the name of his partner
but they do basically clowning and it's
really incredible if you ever get to see
villerwin's work
go check him out um but they they did
this thing where they would walk through
the audience at intermission and pulled
two kids to do a comedy sketch with them
in the second half and they actually
pulled my brother
so he was on broadway before i ever was
and i was very upset about that at the
time
were you also in attendance at this show
i was not young and cute enough i don't
think my brother is a very cherubic
little boy so i think he grabbed him
right up
so you grew up in the city uh you'd
already been bitten by the performer bug
so what kind of stuff did you find
yourself involved involved in
high school because new york is an
excellent environment for this like you
can actually have
uh meaningful exposure and experience
quite young yeah well and the great
thing too is there's so many arts
programs around the city so uh depending
on what type of art you're
interested in um there's so many
different places you can go so i did the
abram arts center
on the east side for a little while
there did a couple of just
classes and plays with them and lessons
and um and then obviously did everything
at school and then summer programs
wherever i could find them and
um i basically just have been doing this
non-stop as long as someone will let me
and so you were
driven throughout high school in this
way did you study theater in college
like did you know that you
wanted to perform then yes i went to my
mother
the teacher and i was like hey you know
when you go to college do you have to
take like english and history math and
science and just yeah a little bit so i
said okay well then i'm not going to go
and
she hit the floor and so our
compromise was that i did have to go to
college but that i could do
a bfa program i could do a program where
it was all acting all the time
and really focus in on the career and
the art form that i wanted to
so that's actually what brought me out
to la
i went to uh usc they have a school of
theater at the time and so i
did a four-year acting program of just
six days
of acting all day every day i have to
say
when i i think usc i don't think that
particular program
yes you think of the cinema sure the
school theater was very small
comparatively so are there people from
that
program that we've seen do other things
is it one of those situations where like
they're a bunch of you and then you you
kind of came up together
well i mean yes i mean i definitely can
mention a few of those but even back in
the day forest whitaker is an alum
um we have a couple other really really
big alum who are of course
skipping my mind at the moment but um
but so one of the
really uh interesting ones is uh beck
bennett who's on snl right now
beck was literally in my class we did
plays together all through those
years um so yeah he and kyle were at usc
and now they're in snow which is pretty
exciting
wow kyle ii yeah kyle moody i met them
both
um at snl three months ago now
um it was uh the episode that dave
chappelle was
hosting um so they've uh
invited me and my wife and then we i
just saw the cast afterwards i also got
to meet bowen yang who played me so that
was fun
it's very cool yeah
we had like a nice connection
but that's so fun that uh you and beck
were um
in the same program trying to um
hone your craft and then uh you know
like that now you see him on
tv every weekend well you know i don't
know if you watch us now every weekend
but
well it's fun too is that i've i've seen
sides i've seen sides of beck that like
the world has yet to see like i'm so
excited for him and the rest of his
career because we did a lot of very
you know deep drama work together as
well so i just knew he was very very
funny and he had you know they had good
neighbor which was their sketch group at
the time
um but it's you know i've seen him do
work that you know people the snl crowd
haven't even really
seen wow listen to that it's like the
many sides of beck bennett like now we
we all have something to look forward to
many sides of back bennett he's a
tremendously talented actor
comedy and drama so he's got a big
career that's such good fun and that
that
um that that genuinely does excite me
because
they think about what lies ahead so
while you were growing up
um as a performer somewhere along the
line you got exposed to dungeons and
dragons
so i wanted to ask like uh when that
happened because i have to say deborah
um i played dungeons dragons as a kid
and uh
and um let's just say that you would
have stood out in our group
probably not many girls uh played yeah
yeah there were no girls
at least like our little uh group well
that's been some of the
some of the fun and some of the what
i've been sort of
feel sort of tasked to do with dungeons
and dragons now is i think
i didn't come to it till my mid-20s and
i think some of that was that i did feel
that there was a barrier to entry
that somehow it was like a secret club
and you had to be invited to come and
play and even if that wasn't necessarily
entirely true
that was how it felt as an outsider so i
didn't come to it till
an adult and i think now how much it's
enriched my life and how much i could
have really used it when i was a kid
so my goal right now is to really open
it up and say
and it's been a it's been something that
wizards the to publish d have been doing
as well with this recent edition
is say everyone come and play even if
you don't know the rules
even if you make mistakes this is just
about collaborative storytelling
and um you know learning how to be
spontaneous
um so i i keep whenever i play i keep
inviting new players to come and play
with me that's my favorite thing to do
well i definitely wanted to dig into
this because this is like the i mean
it's like the greatest thing i've ever
i've ever i've ever heard or experienced
god
um because so i'm going to relate my
experience which is probably a little
bit more
customary uh so i'm a bit older than you
um
i you know and i grew up in the 80s
uh and dungeon dragons was one of like
it's like the heyday
honestly like that you know 80s those
dragons the dice what addition did you
start playing
legitimately i think it was like the
original like there wasn't even an
ambition number
so there was there was basic dungeons
and dragons and there was advanced
dungeons and dragons and they had like
different you know rules
um and then there was second edition
advanced stars dragons would try to
clean some of the stuff up
um but but but we were we were playing
like the og
keep on the borderlands like uh um
uh basic set do you have your books
still
um i think they might have literally
disintegrated from all of our
handling of them debra because we had
our grubby paws i like our grumpy
childish paws and like
endless meals people that's good
these volumes um so it was
me my older brother and i'm telling you
the story this might entertain you
um so my my brother is now a professor
of psychology um
at nyu uh he got married like you know a
number of years ago
but my best man speech for him was about
how he was the dungeon master when we
were playing dungeon dragons like i was
trying to like paint a picture of us
growing up
so so it was him me and then our
neighbor
um and then there were there might have
been like some people that kind of came
in and out but really like the three of
us were like the core
because uh you know like we lived on the
same street
um and it was such like a way of
um when you you called it collaborative
storytelling but it was almost like a
way for
you to have this robust uh fantasy life
for yourself as a kid and i was a very
geeky
asian kid uh my brother was equally
geeky
and so then you had these incredible
narratives about yourself as like this
dragon slaying hero going out in the
woods and taking all these risks and
like you know
like having all these achievements so it
was
very very important to my sense of
happiness and belonging uh as a kid
um and you discovering it in your 20s as
a creative
um and then have enjoying some of those
same elements like makes me really
happy um because in my case i associate
it with that idyllic time of life
um and the the thought of people
discovering it
um at later points um is just
like it's just an amazing idea to me oh
cool i mean i think as an actor
so much of it is is about keeping that
inner
child that likes to play and have a rich
imagination alive and that's my job
is collaborative storytelling so this
was just a it's a lovely way to practice
it's a lovely way to
um feel a little bit more ownership over
a story as well because as an actor i'm
rarely writing or creating the story i'm
just sort of kind of trying to
live in it and absorb it so in dmd it is
that really nice sense of like oh this
originated from me in some regard and
yeah
i saw that you were actually writing the
storylines and everything else which is
which is awesome i've really loved uh
game master you know being a game master
and um right you know writing the
stories and leading a team through it's
so much responsibility
it can be yes you have to know all the
rules to some extent and
uh sometimes you know sort of solve some
social
things that go on at a table but i've
had almost
entirely positive experiences so was
there an individual that was kind of
your
introducer uh to this absolutely
so um my managers at the time
one of their sort of junior associates
he had been playing his whole life like
probably started
with the original you know went for
weekends but they would play for 30
hours straight
kind of thing and i always said i was so
interested and i wanted to play but i
just didn't know how to get started and
he offered
to run a game for me and my friends so
he first introduced us
we played with him for about a year and
then
for our next campaign he sort of
suggested that we start to
switch the responsibility of writing
this the campaign
so i was the first one to go and i think
that's when it really bit me
and i said wow i can draw from my own
interests in these worlds and these
genres that i think are really
interesting
because i'm oddly not a big fantasy
person that was never a huge part of my
background i'm
more sort of children's lit that kind of
sort of
imaginative space rather than like dark
tolkien
sort of fantasy so i lean a little more
that way a little more towards innocence
um so for me to be able to say wow this
is just a structure
that i can paint anything on it and use
it
um so i can do something that feels you
know
like a storybook and not necessarily
tolkien-esque if it sort of leans more
towards me so that has been the fun of
the last few years is sort of
putting my own stamp on it
[Music]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by literati kids
if you like reading and you think
children should read this is a product
for
you so great children's books opens up
new worlds for discovery with literary
kids your child can explore
uncharted places every month with
incredible stories hand-picked by
experts so literary kids is a try before
you buy subscription book club each
month literati delivers five
vibrantly illustrated children's books
bringing the immersive magic of reading
right to your home and they've got
age-based book clubs that ensure
appropriate reads so for story time
letting them read on their own i
personally grew up loving
choose your own adventure books i also
love that the berenstein bears freaking
love them so you can get all this
awesomeness brought to your children
with a cool monthly subscription through
literary kids so head to literary.com
slash yang for 25 off your first two
orders it's pretty awesome 25
off folks select your child's book club
and start them on a literary journey
like no other
literati dot com slash yang's the only
place you can find 25
off your first two orders and this one
of a kind book subscription is the most
joyful way to foster
a lifelong love of learning for kids so
literati.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by
athletic greens the most comprehensive
daily nutritional beverage
you are going to find his deal get some
athletic greens comes in little pouches
or like a little bowl of powder however
you want to do it
dump it into some water mix it up drink
it and it tastes great when i was with
my sister she put it in a smoothie for
me it's amazing too but you don't need
it it tastes good and it's this
all-in-one superfood powder by far the
easiest most delicious
nutritional habit you can add your
health routine today helps your gut it
has 75 vitamins minerals whole foods
sourced ingredients it's got all that
good stuff
you get when you eat veggies pretty cool
easy to use and because it's podcast
you can get a discount on athletic
greens and some free vitamin d
so what's that discount you get a free
one year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit our link today
so whether you're looking for better
performance or better health athletic
greens makes it easy so visit
athleticgreens.com
join health experts athletes and health
conscious go-getters around the world
make a daily commitment to help every
day that's
athleticgreens.com and get your free
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs today
oh deborah i i ran for president and
probably knew that
so but but but there was this element um
that i had from dungeons and dragons
um so i i went to law school i my
parents who also like yours were very
into education
um so i went to law school and practiced
law unhappily for five months
and then left to start an ill-fated.com
um but but one of the the things that
drove me
um was i had this quote from myself i
guess i don't know if you're allowed to
quote yourself but it was like that when
i was a kid
growing up playing dinosaur dragons i
didn't dream about being the scribe
like like i dreamt about going into the
woods and
slaying the dragon um with the
comparison being that my lawyer job felt
like
being described like where
i was just like you know like like but
and and the version of law i was
practicing which was corporate
transactions genuinely did feel like i
was documenting someone else's
accomplishments
like it really didn't feel like that and
so then i was like i should try and
accomplish something myself
yeah well there is something amazing
with d and d that it's about practicing
being heroic
even an imaginative place yes that's
where rescuing
innocent people and stopping the tyrants
you know like
that is a beautiful thing to practice as
a kid and an adult
yeah so as a kid i practiced it all the
time and then i found
adulthood to be driving me in a very
different direction and i was
and like and i think one of the sources
of strength i had
to try to start a business or do some of
the things i've done
entrepreneurially was from doug's the
dragons was because like you
had this sense that um you could
paint your own picture of the future uh
and then try to actualize it
uh and i feel like artists and creatives
do that
entrepreneurs do that um in you know in
like positive cases i mean you know
um politicians sometimes every once in a
in a blue moon
but i'm i'm so glad that you saw in
those dragons like this canvas that you
could paint and then you said you know
what like you know
like my version of it is going to be
like uh you know more
distinct to me well there's that i i
think also
it's a wonderful space to if again if
you do it
right and safely with the right group of
people to explore identity as well
yes we don't have to be because the
characters you draw up for yourself
are just versions of yourself the
versions of yourself that you
aspire to be or you're afraid to be or
even if you play a villain
it might be all the things that you're
scared about within yourself
you know and so it is this sort of space
in which to try
on hopefully safely and respectfully of
everyone else at your table
but to try on different aspects of who
you are and see how it feels
and and see how other people respond to
you and what that means and
i again i i think role-playing games
collaborative games are such
rich ground for that kind of exploration
um
again there are toxic tables and things
like that but again the most part with
your close friends i just think it's a
really cool safe space especially for
kids
who are still figuring out who they are
or who they want to be
to experiment with that i'm trying to
get my kids into it um
i've been unfortunately a little bit
tied up right now and i will say that
that has as a parent now the competition
is much stiffer because it's not like my
brother and i had screens around you
know what i mean it was like
you know use your imagination or like
you know like sit quietly in a corner
yeah go outside and play run around so i
i just love that you're this
incredible ambassador for um four
dungeons dragons and role-playing games
and collaborative storytelling um so you
discovered it in your 20s
and i feel like around then i guess your
career took off like around that time is
that
fair to say yeah early 20s is when i uh
booked true blood
and then i probably got into dnd three
years later three or four years later
so what was it like um after
your career started to take off on true
blood um because i i'd imagine
um it's a very different set of
experiences
all of a sudden you were in the public
eye to a much higher extent
um you know i'm sure you got offered
different kinds of roles than you had
previously
you're kind of balancing your own
artistic vision with what
people um saw like
like saw as like the ideal role for you
um all of a sudden you have agents who
like are actually
um you know making money
etc etc so it must have been
like a a period that was like filled
with change on multiple fronts
i mean yes yes and no i think you know
a lot of that happens and then you have
to decide as an individual how much of
it you embrace
um so i think absolutely i got
better opportunity i had fantastic
representation that was
not you know available to me previous to
that
which meant i was able to audition for
more and more interesting
projects um the
in terms of sort of public eye and view
and things like that i
very quickly decided to just step away
from that it i
this is not that strange for actors but
i think people are surprised
to hear it i generally don't like being
the center of attention
um unless i am acting unless i'm in that
space and that's
sort of the most i will confess to you
deborah i'm the same way
yeah i think it's that surprises some
people but i think it's more common than
we
give it credit for it yeah knowing even
when i know about you that makes sense
just a little bit when you've been dorky
your whole life you just sort of go
don't look at me i will say deborah just
on a personal level i just want to throw
this out there this may happen to you
it's like so occasionally someone would
come visit the household
um and uh they'd be visiting my wife or
something like that
um and then they would they would see me
and i think there was like some kind of
meteorific version of me
that like um they might have had in
their minds eye but then instead it's
just like me puttering around and it's
like oh
yeah i don't know if you get this but
because of that i never get
are you deborah ann wool i get you know
who you look like oh i
i have gotten though well i certainly
have gotten a lot of like hey are you
andrew yang kind of
really yeah and then it would be uh
and then um you know i say yes
yeah i think because i don't
maybe put on much of a celebrity persona
that when people meet me i do get the
you know who you look like because they
they don't believe that an actress would
be
at the grocery store and her sweatpants
you know so
um i think it's sort of that space and
then also because i'm
i'm geekier and the roles that i've
played are not necessarily
uh leaning into that aspect of who i am
um
i don't know who people expect to meet
but it's probably not you know
this girl you know um so that yeah it's
been interesting to see fan reaction but
luckily
most of the fans um of triple ed indeed
and uh daredevil have been kind of
geeky like me too so it's been a nice i
resembled that
and i i would have to say that like i
liked you
uh before this conversation like i like
you more now like you're
such like a delightful grounded uh
down-to-earth person
i do want to talk a bit about daredevil
because i was a big fan of that show
sorry i mean you know it's not your
fault i mean like you were one of the
people that made it a hit
thanks was there anything going on there
because like like there was entire
netflix
like marvel daniel like it really seemed
like everyone regarded your show as like
the best of them which i i would
uh agree with you know no not a knock on
the other shows that were out there
but but you know i think you were like
the first major effort yeah we were
certainly certainly the tent pole we
were the first one to kind of test and
see if
it would be you know accepted and yeah
and just the way dungeons and dragons
had a really big impact on my childhood
uh the daredevil comics did too really
oh wow
so that it sounds like was not your
experience like you probably read the
comics after you got the role
yes yeah i wasn't a big comic book
reader as a kid
um uh that so that was that was new to
me and so yeah i found
the sort of the the story lines that i
knew that they were going to be drawing
inspiration from and then the artwork
that i knew that they'd be drawing
inspiration from i went back and i read
some of those runs
um in terms of karen however i was very
happy to hear that they were open to
doing some new directions
and finding some uh sort of new
story lines for her because you know
comic books have not always been
the most fema you know friendly to their
female characters yeah i i like what
they did with
i appreciated it very much as well as
well and so i i didn't necessarily go
back reading so much for content as i
did for sort of
get a sense of what the mood would be uh
yeah how they were going to portray the
series
the daredevil comics were very impactful
on both me and my brother
uh like that there was like the um frank
miller runs that you're talking about
and then there was the born again um uh
uh run which also was frank miller i
believe um
that included karen page though not the
uh netflix version of karen page was
like
we made a nod to it but gave her a
little more agency
yeah and so those characters
being brought to life was uh really um
really fun for for me um and
i'm sure you got a lot of fans like me
who were talking about how
the series meant a lot to them too
because they just loved the characters
for years and years
yeah no absolutely we did and you know i
think anything
that is so strongly has such a strong
following
previous to your iteration um you really
hope that you do it justice and that
they feel like
you are adding to the story rather than
wiping the slate clean even if you do
your own take that that you're sort of
paying homage
um but also the really wonderful thing
i've discovered about comic book fans is
i think
because comic books redo stories
all the time they they reboot and change
things and you know even within
daredevil there's been
three or four sort of repeats of a new
origin story he's been born again a few
times
they're very surprisingly open to
stories being switched up and changing
some things around and characters don't
have to stay
you know karen page doesn't have to be
exactly the quaffed
you know 50s skirt that she was you know
when
they first started writing her they were
very open to expanding on it so that
that's been a really
cool part of i think the comic book
fandom
do you have any fun backstage or onset
stories
it was a while ago um it was a while ago
i mean i have one we were um i was
filming a scene with jl
lee outside the sort of hotel in season
three
uh that was uh the kingpins hotel and i
was trying to get a story or something
like that and we had shot
the scene previous to it before winter
break so early december in new york
where it was still kind of warm so we
were dressed for like
fall january 12th or whatever comes
around and we're continuing the scene
and it is
you know 18 degrees or something like
that and we're in these tiny little
coats so
j and i can't even it gets the point
where we're so cold like our brains stop
sort of understanding words were
garbling my fingers were blue i couldn't
hold my pencil to pretend
right so we kept running inside and
putting our hands over the heating vent
but i
felt very bonded today that day
as we suffered through the cold i do
think it's fun to tell those stories
because
it feels like acting is a very glamorous
uh
uh job and it can be but i can count
those days on one hand
mostly it is being very cold or wet or
covered in blood
that card is blood uh well now people
can track down that scene and like see
if they can find when
the new guys are freezing and whether
they can detect it
you definitely took those characters to
like the next level and modernized it
but also
um really uh preserve the essence of
what made them
so important to so many people uh
including me it was like it was a lot of
fun like i
really was very saddened when that when
that series really like i think everyone
knows that that series somehow got like
cut short like that there was like there
was more i mean we didn't necessarily
know that it was ending so it wasn't
like
you know we could wrap it up maybe in a
way that might have been more satisfying
although i i do like that ending i think
you can imagine the you know um
uh nelson murdoch and paige you know
sort of banner going forward from there
um but yeah i you know i think
with no begrudgements or anything like
that you know businesses do what
businesses have to do but uh it would
have been nice to know maybe like i
you know i would have said goodbye to
people differently i would have stolen i
would have stolen something from the set
you know i would have done all my things
that kind of wrap stuff
up but instead it was just sort of oh
we're not going back and
i had to find a lot of emails
well a lot of people were right there
with you uh deborah
so since then you've been staying busy
are you working on things right now that
you're excited about that your fans
should look out for should be excited
around the corner
i mean because we've been talking about
d d i mean obviously this year
uh this industry has sort of shuddered
quite a bit um i've done a couple of
projects that
um you know followed very closely the
covert protocols but it does add a huge
budgetary expense on top so
you know there's less you can do with
the movie things like that um
so yeah there's a couple of small
projects that will come out uh in the
coming
months and year that i got to do this
year that was really fun um but
mostly we've been talking about d and i
have this series
uh relics and rarities that i made a
couple of years ago that i'm
so proud of and so i
i'm not able to do a second season of
that necessarily
but i have a new idea something else i
would really like to pursue so i've been
slowly working putting things together
pursue it do it yeah
um it's really hard to get anything made
so it's you know small steps at a time
but it's
calling up a lot of my you know a lot of
friends that i've made in this community
hey producers if you're watching this
fund me
is it going to be called relics of
rarities or is it because
that's that was the original show and
that you know that has to say sort of
canned into that
series and uh that company um so this
will just be
a totally new show but with some of the
same people and uh i really hope i can
get it up and running
i'll give it a shot me too this seems
like it would do so much
good in the world i love having guests
on so if you are interested at all maybe
we'll have you i'll reach out and see if
you
can
at least i can do of course i'm gonna
turn my podcast right now like um and
i obviously i can't be saying how
awesome uh it would be for your show to
go and not agree with you yes
so clearly i'll be there if scheduling
works out we definitely should do that
well would love that thank you for
everything you do uh
deborah and uh again i was a fan of
yours before this conversation but i'm a
bigger fan of you as just a person
and artist and creative force uh really
appreciate it and hopefully we will see
the show of yours soon and you and all
sorts of other things because you
improve anything you're a part of oh
thank you so much
that's so generous of you this has just
been such a pleasure and so out of the
blue i would never have expected
to be on your podcast that when uh you
mentioned it i thought oh what a great
you know again another thing that d does
sort of bringing different
you know uh industries and conversations
together so
that that was what drew me to you guys
that's fine
well i saw you did there was the dnd for
dems and i was like this is so
cool it was a very important part of my
life like i
you know i mean like it genuinely i
think did drive me to do some of the
things i've done
um so so i i just i just knew i'd enjoy
uh getting some time lovely to meet you
officially thank you for listening in i
hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you